smooth so you're the new neighbor yeah  I'm Zach by the way  I'm Hannah get away from the window now  I gotta go  hi hey we're just moving in good talk  he's a big teddy bear don't take it  personally it doesn't really like anyone  yeah Hannah's in trouble he's locked in  this house and her dad's a psychopath Oh  does she have a friend  The Abominable Snowman of Pasadena these  are all goosebumps manuscripts why are  these books locked did you unlock a book  oh no I'm sorry  I'll put it back where it belongs  phenomena  the only way to stop them is something  back into the book you've read them all  right yeah yeah if we know the  weaknesses experience all monsters than  you've ever imagined in one incredible  adventure  goosebumps no maybe they're friendly not  friendly  midbus falutin happen be a seat sir